as a conservative for many years growing
up I had no problem reading the New York
Times I I knew that I didn't agree with
you know the slant that they put on many
stories but they had conservative
writers they they thought conservatives
were legitimate and there were all sorts
of things that I could agree with the
old liberals on
um that's gone it's disappeared 2020 was
a watershed year the year in which the
New York Times began firing people for
being old school liberals the year in
which Princeton I went to Princeton
Princeton University erased Woodrow
Wilson's a name from the wood Wilson
school and from Wilson college that was
a year of cultural revolution and that
cultural revolution brought to power a
non-liberal ideology which took over the
media the University's Hollywood
government bureaucracy even the military